ne görüyorsunuz 11 haftalık minik bir
bebeğin el ve ayak izleri Tab Benim için
özel çünkü kendi oğlumun ve izleri şim
burada Oğ olan simi
heac
Kon konu
şu larımız vardı Çevrenizde gördüğünüz
her şey gözünüzde adeta böyle devasa bir
şeymiş gibi görünüyordu kaşık tutmaya
çalışıyordun kocaman annenizin babanızın
ayakkabısını giymeye çalışıyordun devasa
adeta küçük bir kayık gibiydi ama Bizler
büyüdükçe büyüklük anlayışımız da
değişti Artık yaşadığımız ilçe şehir
ülke sıradaki büyük şeylerdi bizim için
sonra dünyaya sığamaz
olduk Ben bir astrofizikçi
üzerinde yaşadığımız gezegeni o
gezegenin İçerisinde bulunduğu güneş
sistemini o Güneş sisteminin İçerisinde
bulunduğu galaksiyi o galaksinin
İçerisinde bulunduğu devasa Galaksi
kümesini ve milyonlarca diğer Galaksi
kümesinin olduğu evreni tanıdıkça benim
için evrenin en minik yeri şu koca
dünya Evet sıradaki slay Evet evimiz
Dünya Bizim 133.000 km çapındaki
Harika süper ötesi uzay
aracımız biliyor muydunuz
dünyanın bir daha basalım slayta H
yaptıysan güzel Evet bu bize zaman
kazandırır ışığın Dünyanın bir ucundan
diğer ucuna ulaşması saniyenin 20
birinden daha kısa zaman alır yani bir
göz kırpmasının yaklaşık 1 biri zamandan
bahsediyorum
ancak ışığın evrenin bir ucundan diğer
ucuna ulaşması 93 milyar yıl sürer 93
milyar yıl Tabii bu deneyi yapmak için
genişleyen evreni 93 milyar yıl boyunca
durdurduğum varsayıyoruz
yani dünyanın Evren karşısındaki minikli
bu Ama bu minik gezegendeki birkaç
milyar insan olarak Bizler evrenin
sınırlarını zorlamaya devam
ediyoruz ğin olan aşkımız yeni değil
bakarsanız bu aşkımızın yaklaşık 2000
yıllık bir geçmişi var ne yapmak istedik
kuşlar gibi uçmak istedik başardık mı
Evet peki bunla yetindik mi Hayır sadece
atmosferde değil atmosfer dışında da
seyahatler
planlıyoruz bununla yetinecek miyiz
Hayır bir gün yörüngeye oteller
kuracağız biliyorsunuz Otel turizmi
mevsim değişimine bağlıdır mevsim
değişim bağlı olmayan bir uzay turizmi
başlayacak bizim evreni tanımak için
kullandığımız ilk gözlem aracımız birkaç
milimetre çapındaki
gözlerimdir Bizler gözlerimizden daha
büyük daha fazla ışık toplayan ve bu
nedenle daha uzaktaki cisimleri
görmemizi sağlayan teleskoplar
yaptık artık öyle teleskoplar yapıyoruz
ki Evrenin İlk yıllarına onun bebeklik
anlarına şahitlik edebileceğiz
1920'lerin sonlarına
doğru Aslında içinde bulunduğumuz
Galaksi evrenin kendisi değil Onun
farkına varıyoruz bizim galaksimiz gibi
yz milyarlarca başka Galaksi Var görünen
Evren içerisinde Evren hakkındaki
bilgimiz arttıkça bu üzerinde
yaşadığımız dünya bize minicik bir yer
gibi geliyor gittikçe gözümüzde
küçülüyor uzay ilk aracımızı
fırlattığımız
artık eskisi gibi olmayacağını
biliyorduk uzay çağını başladık uzaya
ilk aracı gönderdikten sadece 60 yıl
sonra bugün Güneş sisteminde ziyaret
edilmedik gezegen bırakmadık Hatta bir
kuyruklu yıldızın üzerini bile ara
çildir hatta Güneş sisteminin dışına
bile
çıktık Bizim için en büyük engel
atmosferimizi bunu açtık bunu aşmakla
kalmadık evimizden kalktık 400.000 K
öteye uzayda yolculuk yapıp aya gittik
ayda
yürüdük daha da ötelere gitmeyi
planlıyoruz başka dünyalarda başka
Hayatlar arıyoruz başka gök cisimleri
üzerine yaşam kurmak yaşam inşa etmek
istiyoruz Bu anlamda Mars önemli
duraklar biri olacak evimizden
kalkacağız 50 milyon kilometre öteye
gidip orada bir yaşam
kuracağız
bizim ilk modern ev anlayışımız dünya
yeryüzü üzerine yaptığımız ilk tırak iç
modern yapılardan uzayda yapılar inşa
edebilen canlılar
evmiş hatta sadece uzayda değil başka
gök cisimleri üzerine yapılar inşa
etmeyi
planlıyoruz teknoloji harikası
bilgisayarlar tasarlayan insanlara
evrimleşti bunu tasarlamak kalmıyoruz
bunu en yakın yıldıza göndermeyi
planlıyoruz Yaklaşık 40 trilyon
kilometre öteye Evet okudum şeyler
yaklaşık 200.000 yıl önce Afrika'da
yürüyen homo sapiens sapiens türü artık
günlük yaşamda kendisine yardımcı olan
birçok robot yaptık her geçen gün bu
konudaki bilgi birikimini arttırmaya
devam ediyorum Bu da bize aslında
gelecek hakkında önemli bir ipucu
veriyor yaratılan olan
insanoğlu sanki yaratan rolüne bürünüyor
her geçen gün insana daha çok benzeyen
robotlar
tasarlıyoruz İnsanın su robotların çağı
çok
yakın şimdi tüm bu iyi haberlerden sonra
Yahu biz harika canlılar mışı diye övüne
bilirsiniz ama gerçekten acaba öyle
miyiz Bu sorunun yanıtını bir
astrofizikçi herhalde ancak böyle
bilebilir oturam evrene baktığınız zaman
en bol element
hidrojendir vücudunuzdaki en bol element
de
hidrojendir evrendeki element dağılımına
baktığınızda bolluğuna baktığınızda aynı
dağılımı görürsünüz herum hariç Bu size
neyi gösterir Bu size evrenin bir
parçası olduğunuzu gösterir ve evrenin
de sizin bir parçanız olduğu
Bu övünecek bir durum mu Bence evet o
nedenle düşünebilirsiniz ki bizler özel
Camız Tabii bu kadar kendimizi överken
Öz eleştiri yapmadan da
olmaz acaba Bizler özeliz ok sorun yok
acaba Bizler gelişmiş canlılar
mıyız bizim en büyük sorunlarımızdan
biri şu anda dünyanın başbelası en büyük
sorunlardan biri küresel ısınma
Acaba bir gün küresel ısınmaya çözüm
bulabilecek mi
insanlık ya da bu gezegeni bizimle
paylaşan diğer
canlıların beni öldürme çığlıklarına
kulak verip onları öldürmekten
vazgeçecek ya da bilimsel gelişimin bir
sonucu olarak daha iyi yaptığı silahları
bu gezegeni ve gezegen üzerinde yaşayan
canlıları yok etmek için kullanmaya
devam edecek ya da savaştan kaç minik
bedenlerin buz kesmiş
bedenlerin
Oltan çıkacak mıyız acaba Acaba
gerçekten gelişmiş birer canlı
olabilecek miyiz Ben Bu sorunun yanıtını
bilmiyorum Bir astrofizikçi olarak
Bildiğim tek şey emin olduğum tek
şey Bizler varoluştan itibaren aslında
bir yolculuk
halindeyiz Ortalama bir insanda 10 üzer
27 atom bulunur bu atomlar nereden geld
kend sorarsanız önce büyük patlama son
ölen yıldızlarla
Yani sizi oluşturan atomlar aslında
birer Gezgin hiçbir zaman bir yerde
sabit durmamış hiçbir zaman da
durmayacak O nedenle Bizler dünyada var
olmuş olabiliriz ama burada yok
olmayacağız Burası
kesin bir gün gelecek bu gezegenden
ayrılmak zorunda kalacağız ya isteyerek
ya İstem o zaman Önemli bir karar
vermemiz gerekecek insanlık
olar acaba bui tereden Karl
yüzümüz mız Yoksa onu bu gezegende
bırakıp öyle mi gezegeni terk edeceğiz
Eğer karanlık yüzümüzü yanımızda
götürürsek olacak olan şey burada devam
ettirdiğimiz kaosu evrenin diğer gök
cisimlerine taşımış oluruz dilerim Bir
gün bu gezegeni gerçek anlamda gelişmiş
birer canlı olarak terk
ederiz uzay bilimlerinin Bu anlamda
önemi çok büyük Uzay Bilim ve
teknolojilerini her zaman kariyer
hedeflerinizin içerisine koymanız gerek
buradan anne ve babalara bir mesaj
vermek istiyorum onlar çocuklarından
daha çok endişeleniyor gelecekler
hakkında Sayın Anneler ve babalar
çocuklarınızın hayal gücüne Gem vurmayın
Çünkü dünyayı değiştiren insanlar
Hayalperest idealistler ve bizim o
insanlara çok ihtiyacımız var gelecek
uzayda
teşekkürler